the first question
from anna waldman brown and the question
is uh hey i'm studying automation with
the work of the future task force i'm
curious how you disambiguate between
automation replacing innate intelligence
versus acquired skills slash education
i.e do you know of cross-national
analyses that compare across different
skill regimes
well
you can look at the literature that
examines the acquisition of different
skill regimes so how fast you learn
and that's pretty much identical with
general cognitive ability
once you've learned a skill if it's
automatable
then
cognitive ability iq let's say
iq is cognitive ability adjusted for
age and normalized basically but
if if the skill is automatable once you
learn it iq no longer predicts how well
you do it
and so you can derive a general factor
of of cognitive ability by looking at
skill acquisition rate across any range
of skills you
you can imagine it's that general a
factor
now whether
ai can replace general intelligence
that depends to some degree on exactly
how you define intelligence um
you can define it as the first factor
that emerges
across tests of ability that require
abstraction
that's a good way of defining it
it isn't obvious to me that we have
intelligent machines that fit that
criteria yet
and then discriminating intelligence
from consciousness that's also a very
tricky problem
so
we do have
ai systems that can
replicate complex automatable processes
right the next question comes from
timothy mccormick
for the first time since the industrial
revolution the population of the western
world is declining and soon the entire
world
fewer humans mean the labor force will
contract and the price of all sorts of
labor will increase
capital means of production in other
words will be in surplus while labor
will be at a premium
how how will this dynamic where money
will be cheap and labor increasingly
expensive affect capitalism
i think that that's far enough out in
the future so that we can't tell
because
we're on the brink of
explosions in all sorts of technology
assuming we don't decimate ourselves in
in the next few years
and by the time we hit the point of pop
of radical population decrease things
will have changed so much that i don't
think that question is answerable i mean
obviously one of the things that's going
to happen is that
our ability to produce
quasi-intelligent machines will
address the labor shortage to some
degree
but it's too far
the time horizon's too expanded for me
to speculate i don't even know what's
going to happen in two years let alone
20. i do think the population
decrease
is
i don't think it's a good thing everyone
seems to think it's a good thing except
perhaps elon musk i don't think it's a
good thing at all i think it's
indication that society has lost its way
in a fundamental sense to see uh
population
growth fall below replacement it hasn't
happened everywhere i mean there'll be
more people in nigeria than in china by
the end of the century which is quite
the stunning statistic
and and certainly the west is doing its
best to empty itself out as rapidly as
possible but it's also korea korea has
an extremely low birth rate
japan has an extremely low birth rate
it's a sign of
it's a sign of the demoralization of a
population in my estimation
so um the the next question comes from
deborah scalabrain hollanda and the
question is recently in the name of
promoting diversity and inclusion many
companies have been adopting selection
criteria that prioritizes individuals
based on their minority status what are
some of the unintended consequences of
these strategies and is it possible to
reconcile these goals with the best
interests of shareholders
well it isn't just diversity inclusivity
let's remember it's also equity
and it's interesting that equity wasn't
in that list because it's by far the
worst of the three because the equity
claim is essentially predicated on the
notion of equality of outcome which is
first of all impossible to define across
all possible variables of outcome and
would require something approximating a
totalitarian state to ever impose
people who think diversity inclusivity
and equity just means we're no longer
racist have no idea what system of ideas
is driving this entire enterprise
which is also predicated on the idea
that our implicit cognitions as measured
by the implicit association test are
fundamentally racist despite our
explicit wishes and even more
preposterously that those implicit
biases can be modified by explicit
training programs which isn't even
justifiable by the tenets of the theory
itself
and so what are the consequences of
implementing that well i can tell you
what's happening in the research
enterprise in canada and this is
happening in the us too
you can't get a research grant in canada
and all you mit stem types who aren't
don't have a political bone in your body
have better be watching out for this
because you're going to get
steamrollered by the ideologues who have
a way better grasp of political reality
than you guys do while you're
concentrating on your vitally important
research as you should be
in canada you can't get a research grant
to do
engineering or or hard science work
unless you write a diversity statement
well now you've subsumed your science to
the diversity claims it's like and here
let's let's think this through okay so
i've been an academic at high level
institutions for 40 years basically
including mcgill whereas a graduate
student and i've watched hiring
committees operate at the universities i
defy anyone to find any hiring
committees that have ever been
established by anyone ever anywhere in
human history that have been as fair
in their application of the demand for
competence as university faculty hiring
committees
we've never done better ever than we did
in the last 30 years and now we're
willing to swallow this
absolutely preposterous notion foisted
on us by incompetent hr professionals
who are under trained accusing us of an
implicit bias that we can't control that
they could fix and should fix and have
to fix by the way by the imposition of
these
incredible scientifically unjustified
training programs and so what's the
consequence of that
let
moralizing fools run your important
enterprises and see what happens
now i noticed that mit for example
dropped the uh
math s.a.t requirement
well you you know what you guys they're
the greatest engineering school in the
world you know that actually turns out
to be important
really important and now you say well
objective tests they don't matter it's
like yeah well good luck with that
proposition
so
it's i cannot understand how business
people and academics for that matter who
are perhaps even worse can be so blind
as to let in a fifth column essentially
predicated on the notion that capitalist
systems and patriarchal systems in
general are fundamentally unjust and
racist and then to promote that as
evidence of their open open-heartedness
and
willingness to deal with racism it's
it's beyond comprehension to me and we
will definitely pay for it
we are paying for it already the next
question uh comes from james camp uh
getting back to capitalism now uh can dr
peterson speak to the emergence of
stakeholder capitalism
is it stake is stakeholder capitalism
already priced into shareholder primacy
given the fact that maximizing
shareholder value also requires
attracting the top talent creating a
sustainable workplace environment
addressing concerns with customers and
so on
well i've always had some trouble with
the idea of maximizing
stakeholder return because it
immediately begs the question of time
frame
for me it's like well over what span are
you calculating that
is it a quarter is it a year is it five
years is it ten years i suppose if
you're a pension investor then that time
frame matters right because you'd be
willing to put up with relatively low
returns over a five-year period if you
could see a company investing such that
the returns would improve in the future
um
there's so i don't exactly know what
maximizing shareholder value
means because of the time frame problem
um i would say however that
despite the fact that that's problematic
because of time frame i see absolutely
no indication whatsoever that the
imposition of external ethical
structures say in the guise of esgs
which basically are manifestation of
stakeholder capitalism
that's that's just a proxy for
centralized control
and the whole point of the free
enterprise system is to produce a
maximally decentralized computational
system and if you think you could
subsume that to your utopian vision well
then you don't understand the system or
you overestimate radically both your
intelligence while your intelligence
your ability to see the future and your
own ethics because i have enough
suspicion of who i am let's say so that
i would just as soon like to leave other
people alone to do their own thing just
in case i might be wrong and somewhat
malevolent but you know if you're
possessed by a utopian vision
we're going to remake capitalism to
serve the planet whatever that means
then all of a sudden all those other
considerations including that of your
own ignorance just fly out the window
and you have endless justification for
everything you do because
saving the planet is an emergency
and also an ethical demand if you
swallow the line that's so compelling
that there's nothing that's outside of
necessity and
it's a catastrophe it'll be a
catastrophe in my estimation and here it
comes you can see it esg marching
through the marketplace now
it's really it's going to make diversity
inclusivity and equity look like child's
play
at least because the center
centralized control isn't technically
possible
that's the problem right i mean i can we
agree on that or not you can think of
the market as a giant computational
system and what is it doing it's trying
to reduce uncertainty by
as a consequence of trial and error
error at micro domains so each micro
domain is the individual purchaser and
are they right or wrong we don't know
what we see is the
system moving in a direction that's the
sum of all those minute decisions and
you think you can replace that with some
vision of centralized top down control
well
who do you think you are exactly to make
that claim i don't i
would you replace voting
the same way
because as far as i'm concerned it's a
reflection of the same issue
the voters are picking foolish policies
that will destroy the planet
it's like
they're voting with their money in the
free market
well so a related uh policy question
that came up is this
what do you think of guaranteed income
since economics is under politics is it
ever possible to justify this in a
capitalistic system
that i don't know i mean we do that to
some degree with pensions
right in some sense that's already the
experiment of guaranteed income
um
and are people relieved and happy
to be to be
to be living a life absent the demands
of economic necessity well the answer
that isn't obvious you know i mean i've
seen lots of people transition out of
the workplace into a life of leisure and
then
just perish
you know i mean work is not merely
what moves bread from the
from the store to your plate and from
the plate to your mouth it's also for
many many people it's their prime
source of
the gratification that comes in
engagement skillful engagement in a
productive enterprise and
you could say well a guaranteed income
lifts that burden from people and
you i would say you could try that out
very carefully experimentally at a small
scale in multiple places and carefully
assess the consequences but we have no
idea
how much striving forward is
is
motivated by necessary brute necessity
you know one of the things that wealthy
people do and everyone who who has a
plethora of
of of material resources at their
disposal wrestles with this is
how do you provide your children with
optimal deprivation
in a land of
infinite plenty
and you need to do that because
well they can't just be hooked up to
feeding tubes that take care of all
their needs you know it's
that isn't what life is like
so so i think the only way that can be
that can be figured out in some sense is
experimentally and and there there are
no shortage of pitfalls what you one of
the things you learn as a social
scientist
is that
first of all you shouldn't do
large-scale social experiments
that's a big mistake because your stupid
experiment is not likely to go the way
you think it is and that was really well
documented in
the literature assessing large-scale
interventions to try to ameliorate
anti-social behavior in children some of
which made it much worse
you know with all good intent there and
and and having implemented programs that
everyone regardless even of their
political belief would have thought were
positive and and beneficial
things go wrong for unintended reasons
that's part of the conservative ethos
let's say but also the ethos of any
intelligent social scientist
and so you might say we probably also
decompose the problem
do you mean a universal income for
everyone
and then how much of an income and then
when does it start or do you mean for
specific populations like it's a very
complicated problem and it likely needs
to be taken apart in a very
sophisticated way and then tested bit by
bit
you know the the universal inc or
universal benefit for children
that's a that's a kind of an interesting
idea um there's some evidence that that
helps cut child poverty and maybe the
detrimental effects of absolute
privation
but
but there's always the possibility of
unintended consequences and so
don't be thinking that you know if you
think
poverty is caused by lack of money you
think that giving poor people money will
solve poverty but if poverty isn't
reducible merely to the absence of of
of
of of money then
the provision of money might even make
it worse i had clients who
had a variety of personality problems
and addictive tendencies and they did
fine except when they got paid often
unemployment and then they were done for
like three days
off you know
with their parasitical friends
destroying themselves and
money certainly wasn't going to fix that
problem
quite the contrary so
this is maybe where your psychometric
testing would come in because if you
have multiple factors that you can use
to make these kinds of choices and
policies you might have a better chance
of success
yeah well we also you'd also need a
plethora of outcome measures right
because if you if you define poverty
only as income then you you've you've
essentially accepted the proposition
that the only valid measure of success
is is monetary status and that's a
foolish assumption you know you i think
a multi-dimensional approach one of the
things i used with my clients and this
plan program that i put online future
authoring is predicated on this is so
someone who isn't poor
has an intimate relationship has a
family that functions has friends that
they interact with has a job or a career
has a means of using their leisure time
productively
is engaged to some degree in the civic
community
uh
takes care of themselves mentally and
physically and can maybe regulate their
regulate temptation something so there's
eight dimensions and if you're doing
well in all those dimensions even in the
absence of material plenty which does
happen from time to time then by what
means are you poor
and that's a much more
i'm not saying it's perfect and i'm
certainly not saying there shouldn't be
other approaches but it's a much more
nuanced approach to what constitutes
poverty than the mere absence of money
from garrett maples
and the question is this china has
managed to create an economy in similar
size to the us while blending a command
economy with a capitalist one does this
undermine the argument that u.s branded
capitalism is the best version
well we'll see how the chinese do at
trans power transitions
see the thing about a thing about a
unidirectional and even a an
authoritarian state is that it's
possible now and then that it can be
more efficient if it gets lucky and is
going in the direction that works at the
time
and that's fine
until something changes
which it most certainly will and one of
the things that's so amazing about the
united states and i've watched this
happen time and time again because i'm
old enough to have seen it is that
no matter what problems emerge
in your country
there's a bunch of people somewhere who
are already working to solve it because
it is a free country and it is
characterized by genuine diversity and
and distributed autonomy and so
you guys go in the wrong direction and
you hit a wall and what happens is a
bunch of people who were working in the
opposite direction pop up and say hey
over here this is working how about we
try this and away you go and it works
over and over and so you might not be as
efficient in the short run now and then
and you might have even said that about
japan versus the united states in the
1980s say when japan was such a
powerhouse and was heading in a single
direction in some sense but the japanese
couldn't manage failure partly because
they couldn't let enter large
enterprises you know you hear that
mantra too big to fail eh
it's like no no no so big it will
certainly fail that's the proper mantra
and the japanese couldn't let their
devastated and archaic systems collapse
whereas you americans like you'll let
things fail or you've been pretty good
at that and what that does is open up a
space for things to succeed and so the
chinese could gain an edge in the short
term but they also have a president for
life and a social credit system and
so that doesn't really seem like
progress to me and i think it will
staltify them in the final analysis
america is so creative you look at
silicon valley i mean you have such a
concentration of brilliant and creative
people there it's unparalleled it's an
unparalleled pool of stunning talent
and
you don't know where the next solution
to the problem is going to emerge and so
you guys are perfectly willing to let a
thousand to a hundred thousand
five hundred thousand experiments
flourish
and so then when something does go wrong
a multitude of solutions are already at
hand and you can't get that in the
absence of genuine political and
economic freedom so
no
i don't have any faith at all in china's
ability to prevail in any fundamental
sense over any reasonable span of time
so
i'd bet on the u.s and i'd bet on the
west you know as long as we don't do our
institutions in because of all the guilt
that we seem compelled to foist upon
ourselves in a in a unthinking manner
i'd bet on free and diverse economies
just like everyone else bets on them
people put their money in the american
stock market and rich chinese do exactly
the same when they're allowed to and no
bloody wonder
so
no
it reminds me of winston churchill's
comment that democracy is the worst form
of government uh out there uh with the
exception of every other uh type of
government that he's ever seen right
right well that that and that's kind of
essential to a to i would say something
like an appropriate conservative ethos
it's like yeah it's flawed
but it's not as flawed as your utopian
vision
you have to accept and you have to
accept that that well and even
appreciate the flaw in some sense
you have to appreciate the flaws in some
sense and that's a that's that's a hard
thing to learn you have to be a pretty
sophisticated thinker before you're
willing to
see the inadequacies of a system as part
of what actually makes it great
and so and i every time i come to the
united states i'm just and i've traveled
across the u.s a lot i think i've been
to virtually every state and pretty much
every major city
and
the
the the wealth of
infrastructure here is stunning
and the creativity of the populace is
amazing and the desire
of people to maintain their freedom is
remarkable and the entrepreneurial
spirit that imbues the country
and that gives it this sense of drama
and purpose is
isn't manifest to the same degree
anywhere else in the world and
you know we could turn everything into
hell with enough stupidity and maybe we
will but
all things considered i'd still bet on
the us and the west
for all sorts of reasons yeah that's a
wonderful wonderful note to conclude on
so um thank you dr peterson it's been a
pleasure and an honor for you to be here
with us at mit
i'm going to turn it over to anusha in a
minute to conclude and to give her
thanks
before doing though i i want to
add a few more thanks um this this event
as complicated as it has gotten was uh
really the outcome of many people uh and
their extraordinary efforts so obviously
the atoms to the society i want to thank
patrick faye
anisha colintari sam hoyk and j.r scott
for making this possible
and at oit i have to thank the
the student life office and particularly
the director nia de young and
and nicole willetts
uh for basically just shepherding this
whole process from beginning to end and
making it possible despite all of the
different hiccups and then their
colleagues patsy thompson and laura
watkin um and uh on that note um uh
anusha i'm going to turn it over to you
and again thank you very much dr
peterson really appreciate your being
with us
my pleasure i appreciate the invitation
i'd also just for a sec i'd like to
thank my producer eric foster and my
secretary jordan spencer and my daughter
michaela peterson as well because they
work tirelessly behind the scenes to
make sure this would work on our end
and i appreciate that very much
yes thank you so much dr peterson and dr
lowe
and
patrick
and sam and professor hanlon and adam
smith society stanton foundation and
definitely mikhaila jordan justin eric
uh it has it took this event took about
a year
uh it was just a cold email to dr
peterson that i i i was like i found and
sending it and i never expected that i
my email would be responded so dr
peterson thank you so much um
uh i could not be more grateful and also
to nicole and neil from student life who
pulled a lot of strength for us to make
this happen on zoom and through emails
and other texts
um and thank you dr peterson uh
for coming it was we are we are having
feedback that this was an amazing
conversation and everybody's excited but
it's too bad
if we were in an auditorium i'm sure we
would hear like a huge clapping
well i'm back in may i'm back in may so
maybe we could do something live then
but this will go out to lots of people
too now because of the way we did it and
so you never know this might have turned
out better than it
then it might have otherwise in any case
so
chris met i don't know why it happened i
mean came from all the way from dubai
for this snow to happen it was very
strange uh but thank you so much i am
overwhelmed i am very humble thank you
thank you thank you
and thank you for our audience to be
here uh we were so happy and we got your
messages thank you
good to meet all of you and thank you
very much for the invitation and the
hospitality
yes big thanks again to uh to our
speakers our planners uh and of course
to you and our audience uh for taking
some time this this friday evening with
us to really explore some of these deep
topics and you know giving us a a place
where we can have these discussions you
know touch on controversial topics uh
and you know and things that are of
great import today so really appreciate
it just a reminder uh please join the
editor smith society if you haven't
already it's free we're going to watch
your emails we're going to be sending
out an email about the giving away uh
the books dr peterson's new book and uh
yeah that is that is it thank you again
for joining this evening and i look
forward to seeing you down the road
thank you so much